[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships I am your host
today Ramsey personality Jade warshaw
and I am joined by my co-host today
Ramsey personality host of The Rachel
Cruz show Rachel Cruz and today we're
just taking calls about your life your
money maybe there's something going on
with your spouse they don't want to get
on board maybe your kids are too
expensive and they're acting up whatever
the situation give us a call today the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five and let's just go
straight to the phone lines we got
Brianna and Washington DC what's going
on Brianna
hi Jade hi Rachel how are you guys doing
doing good how are you
I'm doing well I'm excited to be talking
to you
awesome we're excited to talk to you
what's going on
um so my question is just about tracking
my expenses I'm a freshly graduated
college student who's about to start
medical school in just a few months and
for the first time I will be kind of
managing my own expenses and so just I
guess your advice on on how to go about
doing that the smart way
yeah that's a great question go ahead
Rachel well I was going to just ask uh
do you are you going to be making an
income while you're in medical school
are you going to be working on the side
or or how do you plan on having money
um so I actually have money in my 529
plan my parents were very generous oh
yeah to kind of cover all of my uh
School tuition as well as uh living
expenses oh that's amazing that's so
great so you'll be living off of that
money then obviously with all your
expenses and everything yes that's
correct okay that's great so have you
kind of looked at the amount and do you
know exactly how much you're going to
have each each month
um so not exactly just yet our school is
going to be giving us in the next few
weeks they're like estimated cost
s okay so once you kind of have all the
facts I would for sure start with a
budget and really see what you can spend
and then more than that
um breaking it down by paycheck in that
way to see when you can spend it
um are you using anything for budgeting
now or is it just like you're writing it
on paper
no I I just discovered budgeting from
listening to you guys okay cool well the
budget that we created here at Ramsey
Solutions it's actually my favorite
budget it's the only budget I've ever
used that's digital it's called every
dollar and it does everything that
you're talking about doing which is you
being able to list out your income and
actually put in line items of all the
things that you're going to need to
spend and my guess is for you you can
use it in a unique way because this
number this money is coming out of your
529 so some of your purchases can go
through here but probably not everything
that you're going to spend money on
correct
yes that's correct just your school
purchases so you can kind of budget it
by the 529 money and then you could do a
separate budget for like your personal
money however you want to separate that
but just make sure that the 529 money is
only being spent on those educational
expenses
okay yeah and Brianna you know even
looking at it as you're starting to list
out to prioritize that's another big
thing about budgeting is to know hey
what needs to be paid like what are
needs versus wants right and even kind
of having that discussion because I
think our world can all merge so quickly
that you think some of the things that
we think are needs you know they really
are just wants and so you're going to
want to be able to say okay here's the
amount of money I have to spend uh
that's for my personal use and a lot of
that's going to come from yeah your food
it's going to come from housing uh gas
in your car transportation utilities
like there are the things that we call
your four walls that are absolute
Necessities so making those a priority
first and then anything under that Mark
as a just you know take and say okay
here's everything else I spend money on
and then prioritize that and that's the
great thing about budgeting Brian is
like you get to make the budget how you
want it like what are what are the
things that are important to me that I
want money set aside and I think the key
here is just to know that you're being
intentional that's the biggest thing
about budgeting and some people get all
freaked out and they're like oh my gosh
a budget means you can't expand or you
can't have any fun but all it really is
is you just having a plan for your money
to say hey here's here is the income for
the month from my 529 from other places
that I need
um I'm getting money from and all
together here's the amount of money I
have every month to spend and I'm gonna
just do it on purpose and so it's just a
great Habit to be in it's going to be
rough the first few months Brianna so
just give yourself some Grace you know
we say 90 days have the 90 day rule so
the first three months it's gonna be
kind of wild because you're figuring it
out and that's okay but I think the key
here I think it's one of the biggest
things people miss when it comes to
managing money well and Building Wealth
over the long term being in a habit of
just being doing things on purpose with
your money it's the budget it's the one
mistake people make is that they don't
live on a budget because you end up
spending
so much more than you realize so by you
Brianna creating this habit not only are
you gonna just feel in control and feel
like okay I have a plan and obviously
you're smart you're going to medical
school
we didn't do that so like no trust me
you're you're very smart very
intelligent and there's going to be this
level of of power and peace that you
have over this part of your life
probably much like your studies right I
mean you were probably very disciplined
in school to get to where you are and I
tried yes well absolutely and so and
it's that same mindset but applied to
this area of your life and the crazy
thing is too Brianna as you start to be
intentional about this you'll realize
gosh I want to be intentional about my
relationships oh heck yeah I want to be
intentional about all these other areas
of my life so that's the great thing too
is it kind of just like bleeds
throughout all the other areas of your
life and it starts with that budget so
if you hold on the line Austin will pick
up because we'll give you uh every
dollar plus which means that it attaches
to your bank account so you can drag and
drop transactions because that's another
big part about budgeting is tracking and
knowing exactly where your money's going
that's right um so we'll give you a year
of that for free Brianna because
um like Jade said it's one of the best
tools out there it is to help you with
budgeting it is I love and Brianna
thanks for the call that's such a good
question she's starting such a good
habit now to start learning how to
budget now start going through that
process and I love the every dollar tool
I think it came back came out back in
like 2015 or 16 and I couldn't wait I
was like oh thank God no more like
yellow patch you want to write
everything down but um it's really easy
to organize your money I call it custom
organization for your money because
that's really what it is think about if
you go into your closet it and
everything's just like thrown around on
the floor you're looking for an outfit
you can't find it you know you're
looking for a shoe your stuff gets all
dinged up and it you're not taking good
care of it but when you put everything
in its place you walk in and you're like
okay I know where everything is
everything's taken care of I know that
these belong here that belongs there and
your money is the same way when you do
your budget and you are I always say a
budget should be detailed it should be
realistic and it should be flexible and
when it's detailed you go through like
what you were saying and instead of
putting like food right yeah you're like
okay uh date night
um lunch at work
um you know groceries and you're being
detailed so you're really seeing where
you're spending your money and then of
course being realistic which I think for
Brianna is going to be really important
yeah very important that's a great I
love that word though because I think a
lot of people go into budgeting and
they're like okay we're gonna do this
and yeah we're gonna spend fifty dollars
on food this month and you're just like
oh my God I'm guilty he's gonna like
yeah it's gonna absolutely wreck
everything else so be realistic about
your life you gotta be realistic and
then of course there's that flexibility
aspect the first 90 days the first 60
days it's tough especially if you
haven't done a whole lot of research
looking back on what you were spending
you're just kind of it's a shot in the
dark that's right so that first month
it's like oh crap I thought we were
going to be able to spend you know 800
on groceries it became 8.50 well you're
gonna have to pull from some category
shift it around and as long as it's your
money and not credit cards yes you're
still doing good yes that's right love
it so that's how this works getting on a
budget if you're not on a budget check
out our every dollar budget like I said
it's the only budget that myself and
Rachel use because it works and I'll
tell you this it's intuitive it's I'm
not a tech savvy person and I'm actually
able to use it and it's great with your
spouse it's mobile they can look at it
on their phone you've got it on your
phone every dollar that's how it works
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back
question guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I am your host
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality I'm
joined to my right by Rachel Cruz and I
love hosting with Rachel weegis man we
have a good time out here we have a good
time Jade and we're going to continue to
have a good time into next week because
you and I are going to be Financial
Peace University coordinators starting
next Monday and we actually met some
coordinators out in the lobby at the
break uh so this is a this is an
exciting time we've never done this
before you've done this once but as all
personalities we're all getting on board
and doing it historic yes uh and so we
will be hosting you and I do the same
class schedule different times that's
right what time is yours mine is a 1 00
p.m eastern time one to two Okay kind of
over your lunch break okay and yours is
in the evening yes it's 8 P.M central 9
p.m Eastern so late after the kids go to
sleep that's right May 8th right both
yeah we start Monday so Jade and I are
going to be doing it the same schedule
different times so if you want to sign
up for one of our classes and be in
a Rachel Cruz coordinated class or Jade
warshaw yes coordinated class depending
on your schedule for the day excited I
feel like we should because it's like
we're we're coming out of the gate
together doing this so I feel like we
should like beat all the guys when they
do it later 100 so listen we need you
and I have fun that is one thing about
life we have fun right come join our
Financial Peace University class because
we're gonna have fun we're gonna talk
about money we're talking about budgets
and spending all the things yeah and
help you get peace with your money so
and can I just add this is so okay the
last class that I did yes
um the turnaround the financial
turnaround so we're doing this class
right in five weeks yes you meet twice a
you know two times a week so I think
mine is Monday and Wednesday it's just
for an hour after that five weeks was
over the app the the average family had
a ten thousand dollar turn around that's
amazing ten thousand dollars of paying
off debt saving money everything
combined all of it combined and our
class paid off like over a million it
was like 1.4 million oh my God
unbelievable now there's a lot of folks
in the class but I'm just telling you
this is it works it works this is so
important please get on board so where
do people need to go to sign up at
Financial peaceuniversity.com or you can
go to ramseysolutions.com just head over
there and or you can go on our rental
piece yes you can go on my link
um on my Instagram you can click it
Rachel you got the same thing yep so
it's everywhere and I think they might
even put it on the screens here if we're
lucky
um but guys join us join us it's gonna
be great and get that Financial turn
around yeah guest okay I'm not gonna
start singing you should Disney songs
but I am guys going to talk to you about
something Rachel
okay we're talking about budgeting we're
talking about spending money we're
talking about financial peace and this
article came through
um about buy now pay later
and I have to tell you guys by now pay
later is it's probably one of my number
one most hated
forms of debt because it's so sneaky and
by their own words they're like oh we're
better than credit cards because you
know we don't charge interest right away
and it's four easy payments you know
it's a whole thing and they've
infiltrated so sneakily into everything
I mean it's Amazon it's food it's gas
it's pizza delivery pizza number three
it's everything it's everywhere any
purchase yeah any purchase you make buy
now pay later the debt option is there
it's crazy and it's you know a lot of
folks don't realize how bad it is but I
guarantee you Rachel if because people
use it you know for quote little things
I'm just going shopping I'm just gonna
buy some jeans and they're happy to show
that to the world right yeah but if I
ask somebody hey show me all of your
like show me all your buy now pay later
accounts I bet you they would be
embarrassed yeah I bet you they'd feel
ashamed because they know this is not a
good way to spend money this is not I'm
not being a good manager of my money to
do this and you know this article says
it's less psychologically painful to
spend your money to spend your future
money than your present money and that's
true that's kind of what we see with
debt we know that when folks use debt to
buy that they're spending more and as a
matter of fact when it comes to buy now
pay later that's actually the value
proposition that they're giving to the
merchants because by now pay later of
course takes a cut of everything that
you buy and the way that they're able to
make good on that is they say look we
know that if you use buy now pay later
your customers are going to spend X
percent more and at this point they know
it's somewhere between 12 to 15 percent
more yeah because when you buy that pair
of jeans like you were saying it's like
oh I only have to pay 25 right now well
then I'll buy some other stuff because I
can bump up today and that's fine and
I'll worry about everything else later
on the line so it does it increases so
quickly yes services and it's like you
just feel okay spending more money and
we know that it causes what they call
debt stacking because each time you do
it it's a different it's a whole
different debt yes basically it's not
like your credit card where it's like
all in one statement they're separate
and they're coming out of your account
automatically yeah can you imagine how
stressful that is to have 10 you know
eight of these things popping out of
your account month to month and people
wonder why they're broke now here's the
thing I was reading and it said buy now
pay later firms are not disclosing
because a lot of people think there's no
interest says they're not disclosing the
costly hidden fees in the interest rates
that can be incurred when someone falls
behind on payments it's not the same as
credit cards so it's not regulated the
same and it says especially on longer
buy now pay later options
um they may have an interest rate
ranging from 15 to 30 percent 30 percent
30. that's higher than a bad credit card
you know what I'm saying yes and here's
what really gets me Rachel it says many
people are getting hit with a double
interest because like I said these buy
now pay later if you use a firm clarna
after pay they're all separate and
they're getting they're coming out of
their account separately every month
causing all the stress so folks say you
know what I'm just going to put on my
credit card and pay it off like that so
now you've got it
double interest well and what's hard is
is it such a
again the the credit card industry all
of that like that's been around for so
long it's become an innocence right so
normal but what this is this feels like
an exciting new tactic yeah for people
where they're like oh oh well that's
easy I can do that it's got some glamor
to it yes there's like that level of
like newness to it and the amount of
discernment that goes in sometimes it's
out the window because again it's not
always on these high ticket price items
like it's it's not like you're doing
this for a three thousand dollar
purchase you can you can but they're
getting you with these smaller purchases
and again it's it's it's a mental game
they know what they're doing yeah they
know what they're doing and they're
getting you to spend more of the
retailers love it because you're
spending more at their stores so it's
just it is so not worth playing the game
like you're saying of of balancing and
juggling all of these things when life
can just be simple like it can be simple
you spend with what you have it comes
out of your checking account it's done
and it's done if you can't spend if you
don't have the 25 sitting in your
account in your account you're checking
it account to buy it or the fifty
dollars or the 75 you can't afford it
you've got to wait till you have the
money and I kind of I like doing stuff
like this Rachel I kind of added up all
of the expenses when you go in here so
when you
buy things using debt in this market
which is high on inflation right now
this is what you're really paying the
cost of your item plus let's build an
8.4 for inflation because we know that's
true let's build in the 15 that we know
is the unfelt spending cost when you're
using buy now pay later debt
um and let's go ahead and add in uh that
buy now pay later interest or that
credit card interest that's somewhere
around another I don't know 22 to 30
percent all right so now we're we're up
there we're between 50 and 60 percent
and if you're stupid enough to use it to
buy food Rachel food let's go ahead and
add in that tip twenty percent yep look
at this we're like up 60 60 70 on one
purchase one purchase how quickly it
adds up and people wonder why they're
debt they in debt they wonder why
they're broke they wonder why they're
going paycheck to paycheck this is it
yes and let me just throw something else
out there for the the businesses
find some integrity and stop stop
allowing this on your site I have a
buddy he has a dance business and uh
they sell a bunch of merchandise and
sell a bunch of things on their site and
he doesn't allow it yeah he's like
you're not allowed to use buy now pay
later on my site because I don't believe
in it in Business Leaders if you're
listening and you don't believe in this
don't offer it yeah don't let people go
into debt on that my husband's business
is the same way it's commission based
and they they tried to say oh you can do
this in five easy payments no yep yep
stand up for yourself debt is not the
way it's just a headache man just say no
to buy now pay later and if you're
having to do it to pay for your
groceries and your food and all that you
guys it's prioritizing your budget
that's what we're going back to
budgeting is so key to know so you're
not falling back on these types of
products that is right guys there's a
way out of this and it's called paying
cash there's a reason that we say that
is dumb cash is King this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I am
your host Ramsay personality Jade
warshaw and I am joined by my co-host
today host of The Rachel Cruz show I've
got Rachel Cruz with me to my right and
guys we're taking calls all afternoon
about your life what's going on in your
financial situation maybe you have
questions about things you've read on
the internet regarding Finance or things
you've seen on the news or just
whatever's going on in your life give us
a call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and on this
show man we're always talking about
things that directly affect you and
we're always filtering it through how we
teach money here which is a series of
baby steps you might hear us talk about
baby step one or baby step six you might
hear us talk about things like Financial
Peace University you might hear us use
lingo like gazelle intensity or certain
things and you're like what the heck are
they talking about so here's the thing
if you're a new listener and you want to
dive deeper into the Ramsay baby steps
we want you to go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button okay and what's going to
happen here is we're going to help you
figure out your best next step for your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you're at today you're going to get some
education some knowledge we're going to
put you on the right track so remember
go to ramsesolutions.com and click get
started all right let's go straight to
the phone lines we've got mark on the
line from Los Angeles California hey
Mark what's going on I'm headed out your
way uh this evening Mark to Los Angeles
awesome awesome thanks for taking my
phone call Jade and Rachel appreciate it
you're welcome what's going on a little
bit cloudy out here today oh yeah well I
hope the weather holds up for me
yes I know I don't think you'll get the
sunshine this week but um appreciate it
hey thanks for taking my phone call I
got a question for you I'm looking to
purchase a third vehicle a fun vehicle
and it's approximately 55 000 and I'm
debt free other than our house and I'd
be paying cash for it and I really want
it it's a pretty rare car but I think
the thing is in my heart I'm a really
good saver and I'm a really good giver
but I don't really spend a whole lot of
money and so I'm just kind of torn on it
and in my mind I'm like okay this would
be great a lot of great family family
memories and my wife and three kids
you're already emotionally attached to
it I see I know I know it is Mark how
much do you make a year
um it's usually around 2 25 this year's
gonna probably be around 350. 350. very
good good income
and uh so you said this is going to be
your third vehicle
it would be a third vehicle yeah really
just fun it's a toy yeah how much how
much do you already have tied up in your
other two vehicles
value-wise
um my wife's car is worth about 45
000 and my car is worth about 15 000
daily drivers yeah 15. so I don't know
yeah probably 60 000 I have total tied
up in cars right now
okay yeah because kind of our rule of
thumb Mark is that we don't want
uh more than 50 of your take-home pay
for the year annual take home paid to be
more uh to have you know Motors and
wheels so you want at least half of that
but you make I mean you make great money
so you're going to be under that uh just
yeah just barely under that under that
rule of thumb if you will because we
just don't want so much tied in of your
net worth being in you know things have
wheels and Motors because those tend to
go down in value so quickly so uh but I
mean technically yeah you're you're in
that space are you guys you guys have
good other savings do you have an
emergency fund and everything
yeah I have
um I have about 200 000 cash on hand
okay very good why so much cash on hand
yeah
um you know I had had some Investments
and I we've just we've done really well
this year and so we've had a lot of cash
come in and so I just I haven't invested
it other than just small stuff like
um you know three to five percent
interest in the market and stuff like
that but
um
you know I've got I have other other
retirement funds already set up as well
so we're in good shape it's just um you
know it's one of those things I I'm like
I said I'm such a saver and I'm such a
giver just but like spending that kind
of money it actually has me worried
about it so I'm like Mom I'll just give
give you guys a call because I love
listening to your guys show and you guys
have such great advice and um you know I
just don't want to get something and
have that buyer's remorse or you know
everything's so inflated housing market
car market is so inflated it is but I
think you're doing great and I think
that
um there's things that are part of it's
just part of financial life and
inflation is part of life and I think
that when you're in a situation like
yours where you've done really well with
your money you've been smart with your
money you've got to live life while life
is here to live you know what I'm saying
that's right absolutely and you know I'm
guessing our the the 55k is it going to
come out of this 200 that's cash that
you have sitting or is it separate even
from that
no it it would okay it would it would
come out of that yeah and then have
about
200 000 in retirement and then
um yeah I have about 600 000 equity in
our house very good that's great when
are you contributing 15 or more you know
or 15 to your retirement currently
yes yes very good I've got um saving
that and then also have a pension to
send you that I'm on so
um yeah Mark it's a green light from us
that's fun yeah you think so okay yeah
because the things you know I always put
family first and you know
um this is an experience for you though
is what it sounds like right it's that
and it's all ratios Mark I mean if you
called us and you were making you know
75 000 you wanted to spend 55 000 and
you still had credit card debt and
student loans I mean it would be a
different answer it's all about where
you're at and ratios of your life and
you're in a situation you've set
yourself up so well so kudos to you for
doing
you know the really hard work of that
Foundation of saying hey we're gonna get
out of debt and have an emergency fund
have some other savings on hand we'll be
doing retirement I mean you've done it
all so well you make great money so it's
all around ratios and this is not
um yeah I mean you're in that formula
you're in that line so let me ask this
Mark because we always this is what
Winston and I say sometimes if we go to
buy something that's kind of bigger and
we're like oh my gosh so say you bought
this and you had no insurance it burned
to the grounds you never have it there
you go
does it make you lose sleep at night
besides the fact that you loved it and
it's gone now but just financially does
it absolutely put you in a panic
no no no no I'm we're in good shape like
this I don't owe anything except for
house payment and so
um we're we're in good shape and there
you go I think that's a great emotional
well the the answer from us is yes thank
you so much for that call Mark hey I
love getting to say yes I know
I don't think we say no all the time
so we're like no no sacrifice get out of
debt yes but when you've done it all
it's like this is this is the live like
no one else so later you can live and
give like no one else to say too that
he's he's like I'm such I'm a saver and
I'm a giver but the spending is always
hard and we get that a lot that people
are shifting that so so actually
enjoying your money enjoying the money
that you've worked for enjoying the
progress that you've made with the money
you have like absolutely all of that is
a reason to celebrate and to enjoy life
and I love I want to highlight this
because I think sometimes you know
Rachel it's intense what we're teaching
and preaching over here it's intense and
I think sometimes people follow that
intensity pass baby step three and they
don't take those moments to go okay like
I paid off my debt I saved up this money
like I can do a little something
something for myself that's right and
sometimes people speed right through and
they want to pay off their house before
they do something like upgrade or buy a
car and I'm like guys no chill out like
just cool out for a second and enjoy all
this hard work that you've done when
it's within reason that's that's right
we laid out the math for him there's
there's method to the madness it's not
just go spin spin spin but man you got
it learn to enjoy some of this you've
done the work and um you can give your
money you can save your money and you
get to spend your money that's a big
part so love it Mark that's I appreciate
I appreciate the call because then
um because like you said Jada can be
it's a psychological game almost that
once you have sacrificed and saved and
put things away and said no no no saying
yes to yourself can be difficult and it
can be hard so that's why I think
looking at the math
is so helpful because math doesn't have
emotion like it doesn't care but when
you see it you're like okay good that's
less than 50 of what we make a year is
tied up and you know in Motors and
wheels and all the things
we're in a place that we can do that
okay this is smart this is wise that's
the math and that's where logic really
can come into play when your emotions
are all over the place I love that math
math doesn't have any emotions I love
that and look don't let the economy
don't let what's going on in the world
when you've done well don't let it don't
let it scare you into not being able to
enjoy yourself don't let it you
with fear and that goes on each side you
know whether you're trying to get your
money in place while you're trying to do
the right thing it's always the right
time to do the right thing so don't let
anything hold you back don't let the
things scare you this is life life is
cyclical there's ups there's Downs
that's the way the economy goes don't
let that scare you I'm proud of Mark he
gets to buy himself a new car this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
show I'm your host Jade warshaw joined
by Rachel Cruz and we're taking calls
today your life your money triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call and Rachel today is a fun
day man do you know why why Jade because
I'm here we are giving away Dave's money
while he's out and we love giving away
his money does he know that we're giving
away his money it doesn't matter Jade
we're doing it we're doing it all month
long you can enter to win the Ramsay
cash giveaway it's uh you can win up to
500 or a three thousand dollar grand
prize for real three thousand dollars
that's a lot of money all you got to do
is go to ramsesolutions.com giveaway and
make sure that you enter on a daily
basis you can enter every single day
guys and you're going to increase those
chances of winning when you do there's
no purchase necessary except you do need
to be 18 or older to win so you know
don't have your kids out here doing it
it's got to be the adults and today just
keeps getting better because and I love
this the ten dollar sale is bad it's
here
um not only are we giving away money but
we're knocking down prices as low as 10
bucks man Dave he's he's going to feel
this in his pocket a little bit this his
pocket's probably itching right now uh
right now you can get all the books and
tools that you need to learn how to
start Building Wealth find a career that
you love improve your mental health and
deepen your relationship so we got own
your past change your future baby steps
millionaires Total Money Makeover know
yourself know your money redefining
anxiety from purpose to paycheck man
this is crazy ten dollars ten dollar
holla that's what we used to call it
there's so much good stuff in it
honestly like a lot and it's great to
buy stuff to give away to other people
as well so that's all that's always it a
lot of people will load up on the sale
because yeah there's there's so many
good deals and they can give away spread
the love changing your life for the cost
of a burger and fries that's it I know
that's right that's something
ramsaysolutions.com is where you need to
go
ramseysolutions.com and
it's time for a question of the day this
is our question of the day that's
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly.com is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home from locally owned businesses like
air serve dryer invent wizard Precision
garage door service window Genie and
more for your expert help with just
about anything that you need you can
visit neighborly.com and today's
question comes from Cassie in Oklahoma
my husband thinks that we should
continue to financially support his
adult child through college however we
can barely make ends make our ends meet
ourselves each month we are normally
behind on our bills and are in debt with
six other minor children we're obligated
to financially support any input would
be appreciated oh man Cassie yeah I mean
this is tough because in college you
know it still feels like they're still
under your wing right in a sense as a
child
um but once they they leave home
um you know there's that level of gosh
what is what is my obligation as a
parent and I think it's easier said when
they're 21 and they're fully an adult
but when they're in that transition of
college you know it can be a hard one so
for a lot of students they have to
figure it out they do they have to get a
job and say I have to support myself and
this is life and here's what I got to
figure out what to do uh and others you
know don't and their parents are there
to be able to to help support them but
if you guys Cassie can't but if you can
barely make ends meet as is with six
other children living in the home that
has to be your priority taking care of
your household first and making sure
that everyone's okay and if there is
Surplus and you guys still want to help
your child you know who's in school
um that's a gift and to be able to do
that but I wouldn't put Financial strain
to continue that I would make sure that
what you have currently you can support
because here's the deal too if you don't
take care of your home and make sure
that you know the bills are paid and you
guys are current if you guys go under
that means everyone else is going under
yep so just be careful with that you
know and let me throw a little salt on
this as well a little salt in the wound
um I come from a family not of six kids
but four kids and my parents told Rachel
they told us 18. yeah they were like
we're not you're on your own matter of
fact my parents when it came to college
they were like we hope that you're very
smart or very good at sports because
we we didn't you know they we didn't
have college funds growing up and no
shame in that you know we heard that you
walk through the baby steps and are able
to do what you feel you should do but
there there is such a thing as working
through college yeah and I did it my
brothers and sisters did it and I did
have some scholarships but I had a job I
was working these hours and I came out
just fine you know I did not come out
going like man if only my parents you
know and so give your kids some credit
yes that's right take them out of the
nest and see if they fly you know I
think sometimes in in today's culture
people do hang on a little bit too long
and there's that failure to launch there
so very very good very good let's go to
the phone lines we got Lana in
Harrisburg PA what's going on Lana
hey I hope you guys are doing great
um I just have a question
um I am a full-time student and a
full-time worker at the same time and I
am trying to pay off my debt as well as
try to move out but the problem is I
have no credit history so how can I do
all that plus try to save at the same
time how much debt do you have
so I have 6 000 in school day at this
moment and 5000 in medical debt
okay and that's that's all the debt no
cars no nothing like that
and you're in your car that I
go ahead well I was gonna ask you are
you still in school
you are still in school yes yeah so the
school that I'm actually doing right now
is completely paid for through my work
so I don't have to pay any single Drive
which is a blessing
that's great and how old are you
23 23 and when are you done with the
schooling
I graduate in October of this year in
October okay so yeah here here in a few
months and you're looking to move out
are you with your parents
yeah I'm whisper I live with my mom
um in a house and I pay her rent that's
okay okay
and you're looking to move that's great
now I would say
um
a couple of thoughts um right now you're
in school but once you move out what do
you expect that your income is going to
be
so I already asked them during the
interview process of what my income
would be like a raise and they said it
would be up to 18 to 19 so right now I
make 15.50 roughly so that would bring
it up to four and a half five dollars or
left and you're gonna you plan on
working 40 hours
yep I'm still going to be working the 40
hours okay
so what I would do is I would be while
you're paying your mom rent I would keep
a very good record of that make sure
it's like you know you're writing your
check or you can see that transfer
because when it does come time to move
out if you don't have credit which I
don't recommend getting involved in
credit in any way shape or form they are
going to want to see that you have been
paying and all of that goes to help you
so make sure you're keeping good record
um of what you're paying your mom and
then from then on it's just about
creating that plan we're going to pay
off this debt as quickly as possible
it's great that you're not incurring any
more student debt or anything like that
so we're just working to pay off this
debt and we're getting on a budget and
once you can kind of see on paper okay
these are my expenses this is what it's
going to look like for me
um start looking in your area and just
doing your research to find out what is
it going to cost
um to I mean what's it cost in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania for a you know
one bedroom apartment
Harrisburg like an hour and a half and a
half okay so right now I'm looking at a
roughly 600 to 800 depending on if I go
through an agency or if I go there
privately are you uh how much you paying
your mom in rent
so right now I am paying her 450 so it
is lower
um but I do help out with the groceries
so kind of even okay yeah yeah that's
great yeah and so and I think
um just so you know we've even done
research and Anthony O'Neal who used to
be a branching personality here he did a
whole video on calling apartments to
rent to see how many actually asked them
for a credit score and it was only like
three out of like 25 or something crazy
so you can still rent an apartment
without a credit score they may want
first month's rent last month's rent and
a security deposit up front uh
especially if they don't have your if
you don't have a history of credit
they're going to want to know that hey
she actually has the money to be able to
do this
um so I would have all that ready but
yeah I think it's I think it's a great
step and even if you have debts it's
still okay to move out and get your own
place and and start launching that just
know you're going to be losing a little
bit it's not gonna be as cheap as Mom
but I think that that's okay I think if
you're in a position that you want to
start living on your own Lana I think
that's great step I'm proud of you Lana
making strides love it well that does it
for this hour of this show be sure to
join us next time and remember when it
comes to changing your life and your
money you can tell me that you won't do
it but please do not tell me that you
can't With God all things are possible
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help you build
wealth we help you do work that you love
and we help you build actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Ramsay
personality Jade warshaw and I'm joined
by my co-host Rachel Cruz host of smart
money happy hour host of The Rachel Cruz
show and we're taking your calls today
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
whatever you call in with we're going to
talk about it whether it's something
going on with college how are you going
to pay for college what to do with your
student loans uh how to buy a car how to
buy a house whatever it is give us a
call we want to take your call and we're
going to go to Andrew and Alberta Canada
what's going on Andrew what's up in your
world
thank you for taking my call I really
appreciate your time you're very welcome
so I'll just get uh my question's pretty
short uh long story short is my wife and
I are both ready for it uh we're on baby
steps four five and six we could be on
seven
um we don't have much of a mortgage left
we have about a hundred and eight
thousand and I really want to pull from
our retirement accounts just to finish
paying off the house but my wife's a
little bit hesitant and so I'm just
wondering if it's a good idea or if it's
not
um
so most of the well all the time Andrew
at least here in the states we do not
recommend Cashing Out retirement because
there's fees and penalties before you're
59 and a half uh and in Canada what is
there what's the what's the age limit
there for pulling retirement
well like oh man it depends like um I
just know like we because you guys have
a Roth IRAs we have the tax free savings
account yeah so when our tax trees
they're basically maxed out so we have
about 150 cash it's in like a GIC uh
that's cashable at five percent for two
years
um and then the other 100 and whatever
thousand is all mutual funds and we're
investing about a thousand dollars a
month into our accounts okay
no are the mutual funds is it within a
tax-free system for specifically
retirement or is that more just overall
investing and there would be no
penalties except for taxes
uh
there's no penalty so I could take it
out whenever
um I just know so like all in all
between like because I have locked in a
retirement accounts that I can't touch
till I'm 65. and we have our tax free
that's liquid it's still invested at
like five percent
um but the thing is so we have close to
300 sitting between all the accounts and
that our emergency funds like another
40. okay so what's your income
uh it's it's varied it went from about
180 down to like 30 and then it went
kind of back up to about 120. what do
you do so
um my wife's a nurse I do water and
sewer uh but we actually ended up moving
overseas for several years uh like as
missionaries okay so we we literally
went from 180 back down to like 30 and
then uh now we're back working and so
it's up to about 120. okay well Andrew
you guys make great money you could you
could pay off the house with just the
money you guys earned in three years
absolutely how quickly do you think you
could do it because we think you could
do it in in two three years
well our mortgage is up at the end of
next December and then um we obviously
don't want to renew because our interest
rate is so low it's at like 1.8 percent
so I think we could do it we could
probably get it down to about half by
the end of next year the thing is we've
had house repairs I've had some medical
bills that were all cash flowing we
haven't had to touch our emergency fund
um but the medical stuff is the big one
like it's it's fairly substantial that I
have to pay so that's been yeah so you
said something I just want to clarify um
for myself any maybe anybody listening
am I did you did I hear right in Canada
your mortgage is variable for a certain
amount of time and then it has the
ability to change is that correct is
that what you meant when you said the
mortgage is up
uh so ours is a fixed rate at one point
eight percent until the end of next year
and then we would have to renew at
whatever the current rate is with our
bank so you're trying to avoid it going
higher
yeah so honestly even like I'm I'm
really a go-getter like I want to be out
of debt so bad I'm kind of OCD about it
my wife's very hesitant which I
understand because she's more cautious
which is what I need but uh we're just
in such a good spot financially that I
just see like let's just pay off the
house be completely debt free and then
just stash cash away as much as possible
you're in such a good spot um what would
happen I mean how how far could you cut
down your finances because what I would
do I would even go for a year and say
how much can we pay off on this for a
year and try to cash flow that I mean if
you had non-retirement you know money
set aside that were Investments you know
you could pull from that but it sounds
like I just want to make sure we
understand his Investments correctly and
I kind of a hundred thousand dollars in
the mutual fund is that based on
retirement uh Andrew is that just
overall just general investing you guys
are doing but thinking uh so so we have
about 110 in locked in retirement plans
that we can't touch over 65 that's all
mutual funds
um
yeah so then in our tax-free which is
like our is that like a brokerage
okay uh just with our bank but then like
the Roth IRA is basically maxed out so
we have about 150 in it now a little bit
less yeah that's like a cashable GIC so
technically I can pull it out at any
time if we're making a bit of cash on it
so it's kind of like if we it's like if
we had Roth IRAs and you could pull you
know you could take out your
contribution at any point at any point
as long as you don't touch the the
growth yeah the thing is Andrew if
things are earmarked for retirement we
just leave those alone and just say
don't catch up for for multiple reasons
and one making sure you have retirement
which I know you guys will but also we
don't want you hit with taxes and fees
and things that are unnecessary to be
dinged with versus just letting them
grow right when you can use your income
which your income is so high as the tool
to go and say hey let's use this tool to
go and pay everything off so what I
would say Andrew is I would I would do
what I could because again you got it's
a hundred and eight thousand dollars and
you guys make such great money that I'm
like oh I'm with Jade I'm like get as
far down as possible and even if you had
to resign the mortgage for six months
right that's nothing it's not going to
kill you so I just I I hesitate taking
anything that is earmarked for
retirement and is not just general
General savings so
um either way honestly Andrew let's be
honest either way you guys are gonna be
fine right you're gonna be fine if you
took a little bit of money out and
you're not you know and it is earmarked
for retirement but you you it's
different right in Canada that you may
not be hit with all of the penalties
that you would be here in America and
you guys want to use it then you and pay
up that's that's great and then continue
to Max our tournament you're gonna be
fine and then if you guys just said hey
let's just buckle down for two years and
use our income and maybe have a little
bit of a high interest rate at the end
of this and knock it out you're gonna be
fine too so either way it's fine and I I
lean to use your income as the thing
that helps you get out of debt I would
too I would too and I feel like there's
probably a way that oh no my wife is
winning this argument right now
basically yeah she is that's totally
what she said I know I yeah that's right
that's where Eileen well there's
probably a way you can increase your
income too for a while I mean you're
both working your jobs if you were
really like as intense as you're saying
maybe there's a way you can both pick up
a little bit of extra work and knock
this thing out I'm excited for you it's
a great and you guys are so young you
really are you're gonna be okay either
way you really are take a day take it
take a deep breath yes you're gonna be
good that's right yeah there's no way to
screw this up I'm excited for them no
matter how you slice it yes two years
from now yeah
you're killing it it's awesome that's
what it's all about guys this is what we
want we want freedom for you the things
that we're teaching is not to hold you
back it's to push you forward so you can
be like my guy Andrew in Alberta Canada
paying off his mortgage that's what I'm
talking about that's right this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
thanks for listening this is the Ramsey
Show I'm your host Jade warshaw Ramsay
personality and to my right Rachel Cruz
Rachel I enjoy hosting with you this is
fun when it's two two lovely ladies I
love it Jade I love that you're here
we're talking money and you and I we're
doing some fun stuff starting next week
I'm excited if you did not hear guys we
announced something super exciting that
me and Rachel are personally very
excited about but this is it we and all
the other personalities are going to be
leading Financial Peace University we're
going to be coordinating the classes
ourselves yeah we are live from the
interwebs we're going to be coordinating
it and we want you to come join our
classes so uh I got to do this last
month with a group of folks it was like
a thousand of us guys unbelievable it
was amazing
um and Rachel and I are the first of the
two ladies first to be hosting that's
right and
um May 8th yep your your class is in the
evening that's right eight eight Central
nine eastern time okay so Eve yeah in
the nights uh after kids go down
dinner's done all of that you can hop on
with Jade or I'm gonna do during the
lunch hour so 1pm eastern time will be
my class and we're gonna do Mondays and
Wednesdays it'll be about four weeks I
think we're skipping the week of
Memorial Day that's right because
there's a lot of things happening there
so to bump that down and if you've never
done Financial Peace University do it
and do it with us yeah sign up and and
it's amazing the the amount of
turnaround that happens with people and
their money when they go through
Financial Peace University it's so
powerful unbelievable uh it's incredible
so Jade and I are so excited to walk
with you guys through it so it's gonna
be so fun so make sure to sign up uh if
you go to FPU financial
peaceuniversity.com and click on a class
Jade and myself again we start this
coming Monday so just a few days a week
from today and yeah we're gonna walk
through the whole class and let's be
honest we want to beat the boys that's
right let's just be honest they're doing
it later this summer don't don't I mean
they'll be great too but I mean if you
can do this between George and Rachel
come on I'm way more fun I mean John
might be funnier John Versus Jade come
on now no Jade's way more fun way more
fun yeah sorry John I might hear about
that later but we didn't even talk about
can Ken's hosting a class Eddie Cullen
everybody's hosting this is exciting
yeah any class jump in uh again the
personalities we're doing it throughout
the summer so different times uh
different days different starting points
but Jades and I starts a week from today
all right guys in the meantime go ahead
and give us a call here on the show
right now the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we got
Daniel in San Bernardino what's going on
Daniel
hi Jade how are you doing good how are
you
good uh Rachel thank you yes absolutely
yeah how can we help
well I have a question
um I want to invest on a house uh well I
want to invest on a rental
um I have a property here and I have a
piece of land
that's about how one and a half acre lot
I only use half of that
in um the other space it's empty so I
want to set another a manufactured home
on a lot and rent it out is it okay if I
ask for a loan for that okay so it's
going to be 50 of the loan because I
already have the 50 before the down
payment
okay how much how much will the total
home be
220 to 230 at the most okay
and how much do you make at your dental
I'll make you bought a hundred and
eighty 180 okay
yeah and no other debt
um no no and do you have any savings
besides the half that you have saved up
for this
uh 44 my emergency okay
that's great so Dana when it comes to
real estate we are all about paid for
Real Estate when it comes to especially
Beyond just your main home that you're
in
um so taking out a loan
even if it's half even if it's 50 I
honestly we I would not recommend doing
that because it just adds in risk and
and even with those types of homes they
do still go down in value over other
real estate like single family homes or
condos
um you know obviously real estate
Market's been nuts the past few years uh
and as you can see it's actually gained
a lot uh the past few years but always
you almost always always come out above
when it comes to real estate except for
these types of homes that you're talking
about I mean mobile homes anything with
a motor and wheels traditionally goes
down in value and so I it would not be
something I would recommend investing in
or especially taking a loan out for
absolutely and it's if I understand
correctly you've got this land are you
living on the other half of the land
yes I am yeah I feel like putting that
leverage on your own personal property
your own personal land at that that kind
of debt especially it just feels I don't
know it puts a knot in my stomach I
wouldn't go through with it is there a
way that you can start saving up cash to
buy something less expensive to put on
that land eventually
I mean there is a weight but it's it's
it's kind of hard because I have to come
up with with everything I have to go
look for that for the for the
manufactured home I have to get uh the
um um to people to do the the uh
utilities so it's a lot of work so and
plus my my work it's kind of hard for me
to do all that stuff instead of just
going to uh
um where that manufacturer and then they
do all the work for me
yeah I wouldn't do it I'm I mean
Rachel's telling you I'm telling you we
would not go into debt to put a mobile
home on your property we just wouldn't
do it there's no peace in it I think one
route takes longer and it's it requires
more and sorry go ahead no I was just
going to say it requires more sacrifice
on the Long Haul
um whereas the other one feels like a
quick fix but at the end of the day
there's a lot more risk attached to it
and there's a lot less peace attached to
it yeah and Daniel I'll be honest too
being a landlord
to someone that is a hundred feet away
from you also just plays into your
quality of life you know for some people
it's it works out totally fine other
times that the per if something breaks
or whatever it is whoever's renting from
there is going to be knocking on your
door and you're and you're right there
the proximity of it honestly it it kind
of just sets you up if you if you don't
need to do this you know for some reason
then there's I don't see a need to it it
doesn't fast forward your financial plan
um fast enough it's not this like get
rich quick kind of thing there can be a
lot of headaches involved from a
relational standpoint and also you know
if the person doesn't pay it's like yeah
you're you're on the you're on the fence
for the rent and all of it so I mean how
much rent can you draw from a mobile
home
we're there because I have a couple uh
parties that does that for our two so
they're making about two grand to 2500 a
month I just think two thousand dollars
a month to take out 230 K in loans
that's just I mean it's going to take
you forever to pay that back you could
probably make you could probably find a
way to make more than that and figure
out a way to then buy this in cash does
that make sense you could go out and
side hustle and make 25 to 3 Grand a
month and bring that money in in another
way and then save up to buy cash I just
don't think it's worth it to go into the
debt for it but you know
I get it Rachel everybody doesn't see
eye to eye with us on that pay cash for
Real Estate I think for a lot of people
it's a lot of time you know yeah and
what real estate has become not always
um but what what's ends up happening in
my husband is what he does for a living
so I'm gonna try to like oh let's let's
I'm trying to like maybe get him to come
on so he can talk about you because I
love that because just the headache like
this idea that yeah we're just kind of
real estate and rent it out and make a
bunch of money there's so much it ends
up being a part-time job there's risk
involved the renter does not pay every
single month on time these are these are
people with situations with you know a
death in the family or a sickness a
medical diagnosis a job I mean things
just happen and so again if real estate
is something you love and I come from a
family that loves real estate so it's
not a bad thing by any means if anything
if anything in baby step seven once
you've maxed out retirement with
Investments paid for real estate's a
great option and like so I'm all for it
but doing it in the right order in the
right way because it's it just I just
see it on Instagram I see it on Tick
Tock and like all this pissing yeah it
just makes it seem so easy and fluid and
it's just not that easy and especially
when you take on debt and take on more
risk with it it's just not worth it in
the end yeah I think people forget about
the the risk that's tied to it they're
thinking oh I can cash flow 2 000 a
month or 2500 a month and they're not
thinking about what happens when you
can't rent it out what happens when that
person doesn't pay what happens when
it's not as passive as you thought it
was that's right and you've got to get
into things that you didn't know you
were going to get into so we're trying
to we're trying to get you there we just
want to get you there the safest
smartest way possible and that's why
paying cash people for Real Estate
Rachel Cruz knows what she's talking
about this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
it's the Ramsay show I'm your host Jade
warshaw and Rachel Cruz join me joining
me today as of my co-host guys I am like
tripping a little bit because during the
break we decided that we are going to
pull back the curtain Rachel we are
going to expose ourselves because here's
the thing we we're always talking to you
guys about your budget and how you need
to be spending your money in this is how
this is how it goes and y'all are
probably sitting back there going um
I bet y'all are not perfect I bet
sometimes you go over budget Jade and
Rachel I bet sometimes you guys don't
track your financials Jaden Rachel I bet
sometimes you guys you know spend more
on groceries or more on going out than
you said you were and you're right
you're right you're right it happens man
and so I'm pulling up my every dollar
pulled up my every dollar app I have it
is right here you can see the green
Banner every dollar and uh I'm gonna
look at April because may just started
and I'll be honest with you I actually
want to say something but you guys might
laugh at me what okay since I started
working at Rooms I used to work from
home yeah and since I started working at
Ramsey I spend so much less money
because I'm working I like I'm not at
home oh yes totally I think when my
office was at home I would look around
and be like I need this or I need that
and I spent more money yeah I hardly
spend any money now Sam Sam warshaw is
in the in the lobby and he's putting two
thumbs up because his nose yes yes I
have probably saved us okay so what we
do with our budget Jade all right which
I know not everyone is this because
again I think
you go more detailed with the budget I
go more detailed with the budget for
some people you don't have to you can go
more broad categories if you want right
if you've been budgeting for a while
yeah so I just went through a few of our
months because if there's anything new
added to the budget that's not in an
obvious category we just create a new
line item in every dollar so I went
through February March April okay so
here were our big ones I just went back
real fast okay during the break okay so
summer camps
in February Jade and I remember this
happening I don't know if it's like this
everywhere but in Nashville where we
live to sign your kids up for like cheer
camp at the local high school for the
week or uh Church camp you know if you
go to the church for the day our kids
like you know they're little so they're
doing like elementary school stuff
these people their stuff is signing up
like in in February and it's like it it
was crazy so it's like a waiting list it
was nuts so I had to get all organized
and all this so we had a whole line item
Jade and they're doing like three camps
each through the through the summer
they're each a week long so there's like
a cheer camp Caroline's doing a little
dance camp uh they're both doing Church
camp uh and they have swim lessons wow
that's good and all of this came in
February so I had a whole line item with
with camps that are not cheap I'm like
which granted if you have my kid all day
for five days I get that I'm gonna pay
for it true that but it's a lot so
summer camps was like one that it cost
us way more than I ever thought and I
had to sit there and like redo the
budget to get the money for summer camp
so that was February uh then Winston had
some doctors visits that we weren't
expecting nothing major but just some
just some like checkups and that kind of
thing well they all fell in March so we
had a whole line item for doctors visits
Amelia's birthday is in April early
April but I had but we did a skate party
so I had to rent the skate center a
little birthday thing in my yeah that
was what I was not expecting in March I
was thinking April birthday but now we
have to pay for it in March oh good call
yeah uh and then this past month one of
uh one of our team members Nicole hi
Nicole she helps with my social media uh
is getting married and I was like I want
to get her a great gift and so
you know I figured out kind of how much
we could spend but that you know but I
created a whole other line item for
Nicole's wedding yeah for it uh so yeah
it says stuff I mean it does it will
just life happens throughout the month
and things okay how about you Jade okay
so I only looked at April I don't I
don't know why I didn't go back further
and I I am very detailed like we do
a line item that's got like all of the
giving
um that we want to do and it's like
tallied out um by like tithe by Fun
giving like that kind of stuff we love
giving tips like that's yeah a line item
to give extra tips I love that fun all
right so let's see here right that's a
great thing I need to add that I love in
our giving area in our budget because
then specifically when we go there I'll
be like hey do you want to use some of
our tip budget which makes it something
great because then it doesn't come out
of your restaurant online yeah Rachel I
hear you Jim that's it that's how we
played it for you I hear you all right
so I'm gonna all right let's see here I
would say that the thing that popped up
was my son's school enrollment ah the
application fees for his school for the
fall yeah for the fall look at all this
stuff happens and so I put it just a
separate line item there because I was
like well here it is
um I went over my date night budget it's
in the red I it's red hey yes it is
there's any line item to do that that
enclosed it's it's red I will justify
my grocery budget is not I did not go
over my grocery like I didn't even hit
all of it oh good and I'm just gonna say
this because I said this on live the
other day and people came at me the
average amount for a family of four to
spend on groceries is between 800 to
1200 the last time I checked wow
I spent twelve hundred dollars
do you yeah I do okay you know what I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna fault you on
that because I have a different light
item for did you Costco yeah I have a
household items line okay but just
grocery store just grocery store yeah
and that's what they say and I'm like I
could spend 800. as a matter of fact for
a while I did and then I was like you
know as if you have the margin as you
come up in margin it's okay but there
are a lot of people I did a Facebook or
Instagram live about it and a lot of
people were like yeah me too me too and
I was like I do buy a lot of like
organic eggs the the quality of food to
you buy it you pay for it you pay for it
so that makes sense I mean it just goes
to show there's plenty of space where
you can cut money now kids birthday came
up both of my kids are born in the month
of August the 18th and the 21st
um and so there were more expenditures
there because we weren't gonna do as
much and then it always you know you say
it and then as it starts happening and
honestly the weather became nice and I
was like I feel like it would be nice to
have a few more plants in the backyard
and I got some yes that was not you know
what our I had to come out of another
category for that one Rachel if I'm
being honest with myself you know what
Winston did and not to blame him because
it looks it looks beautiful but in April
we have literally we have a line item
but it's called rocks it's really called
rocks because he got these like stepping
stones to create this like little
sidewalk from our garage to our back
porch uh oh that's nice and it it and it
it was nice Jake because I see the
dollar amount next to rocks oh it's not
just rocks out there we bought some nice
rock doesn't it make you feel weird that
you have to buy rocks
and we put it in the budget we do we're
such nerds yes but again you guys it all
goes back to the idea of stuff is gonna
happen number one yep uh number two it's
your budget so you get to shift
categories you get to figure out like
you're saying being flexible
just categories to make it work for you
detailed realistic flexible and and it
feels like permission it's like yes
there's the amount of money we need for
rocks yes go get some rocks now I'll be
honest I try not to like if something
comes up that I want to do or that quote
I'm going to put need in quotes because
it's rarely a need let's be honest it's
usually I want I try to if I have to you
know do a little magic work on the
budget I try not to ever pull from like
the savings you know yeah I try to pull
it from another category and so like in
this case I had a certain amount
budgeted for counseling but I ended up
not seeing my counselor as much so I had
a little chunk of change there and that
ended up going towards plants yes yeah
but that's great and that yeah that's
the game to play is don't if you if you
guys are past especially maybe step
three uh and you just have some you know
if you have money left over at the month
and you're putting it in a safe and
savings that's what we do and we try to
hit a number yeah every month and it's a
it's a great game of discipline yeah to
go through the budget and say okay where
can I move out because like even our
miscellaneous category can start to grow
yes and I can look to be like wow we've
we can cool out yeah we can like we can
shrink that and pull money here
um are out to eat it had more it's funny
because we spent more on groceries than
out to eat last month
um so we had some margin there yes right
that I'm like okay there's yeah we can
pull money there and you you can just go
through it it ends up being kind of like
this game maybe we're just sick in the
head Jude I don't know what it is but it
feels like a game it feels like a game
because you think okay I can find that I
can find that extra you know whatever it
is and all these categories I will and
again it just it allows the discipline
the discipline to come in so what's one
thing that you
are like if like this I must spend money
on like it's it's a want not a need that
you're like no matter what this has
gotta be in the budget please Winston I
have a I have like a clothing personal
line item and it's not the Rachel with
the Rachel line but then I have a
separate one for like clothes and makeup
and my hair and all that Gotta Have It I
do it's just like my it's my outlet I
feel that I'm the same way I gotta have
my nails done I know I must have my
nails done I just I'm not the same woman
if I don't
[Music]
all right folks go back and look at your
budget and now you won't feel so bad
because you see we're real people we're
all trying to cut cut our way through
this we're all trying to make sure we
stay on the budget and we do this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsay show thanks for
listening guys I'm your host today Jade
warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz and let me
tell you something if this show has
helped you in any way if you enjoy
listening maybe you just find us
entertaining I would suggest and I would
love it we would all love it here if you
would share the show if you would go on
there like the show subscribe to the
show and leave us a review leave us some
comments but only the good comments as a
matter of fact that I was laughing with
Rachel about some of the comments that I
see and sometimes I screenshot them
because some of them are just ridiculous
so only put things that are factual
number one let's not start Rumors in the
comments
um but we would love for you to share
comments good ones we'd like for you to
share it review it um because this this
boosts Us in the ratings it helps us
with the analog is it what is it called
not analog what is it algorithm thank
you James for saving my life there the
algorithm the more you like it boosts it
and so you see it for the next time and
that's good for all of us so we
appreciate that and without further Ado
we're going to go to the calls if you
want to give us a call give us a call at
the number eight eight two five five two
two five and we'll take your call Josie
is in Salt Lake City what's going on
Josie we were just in Salt Lake City
last week we were
I know how exciting yeah thank you for
taking my call today you're welcome how
can we help
all right so I will be graduating from
college in a year which is pretty
exciting and I just want your opinion on
if you think it will be worth it for me
to pursue my masters even though my
husband and I are planning on me being a
stay-at-home mom in the future
okay
um are you
and I mean are you married now like do
you have a I am yes my husband and I got
married in December okay well
congratulations I'm newly married
um and
for yeah staying at home will you guys
want a family soon do you think you'll
wait a little bit have you guys talked
about timeline in that regard
well so that's kind of tied in with the
question and so my my husband just
graduated actually this a couple days
ago with his bachelor's and he's getting
his master's
um and he'll have that in two years and
so if I I graduate in a year I would
work for a year
uh to save money for house down payments
and things like that and then we've
talked about maybe having kids then once
he's out of his Masters or I have an
opportunity to get my masters while I'm
working
um but it would take four years because
it's a summer program for I I have a
teaching I'll have a teaching degree
over the Summers I could get my masters
in four years and we would wait to have
kids till after that and so that's the
thing is but I wouldn't it'd be nice to
have my masters but I probably wouldn't
use it yeah because we would just start
having kids although it's nice to be
educated and especially I mean yeah
you're working women you know that I I
just kind of wanted to have your way in
on that yeah absolutely well I think if
you're doing it from an Roi perspective
you're going to want to kind of map out
Josie okay here's how much this is going
to cost the schooling here's how much I
will make are you able in Utah I know
it's different per state are you able to
graduate from college with the degree
you have and go into the classroom or
you have to have your masters
I should be able to go in the classroom
you can okay so your Master's Degree for
teaching would simply it would be a pay
raise correct
correct okay and that would be the main
reason you would get it is that right
besides or unless just education is
really important to you and you want to
do that but is the main motivation the
pay raise and kind of a safety net you
know I plan on being a stay-at-home mom
but if anything ever happened you know
where I have to support our family it
would be a bit of a safety net because
it would be a pay raise okay and how
much of a pay raise would it be do you
know
oh that's a good question I'm actually
not sure okay that's an important one
because you want to know what the yeah
what you're getting for what you're
paying for
um how much is it going to cost for you
to get your Masters so I would actually
it would be free I would have no cost I
I would have a scholarship oh okay
that's great that changes my thoughts
dramatically I will say
um what about your husband what's his
gonna cost
so he we're both graduating debt free he
also has no cost for his master's we've
been able to work hard and have academic
scholarships so the cost is really just
the amount of time you'll be able to
work full time because right okay
interesting yeah I mean I mean honestly
Josie at that point it's not really a
financial
question it's really kind of a a values
question at that point you know what
what are you what do you want I mean if
you know in your heart of hearts that my
husband probably is going to have a
great job and you really want to be home
uh be a stay-at-home mom which I think
is a very honorable way to live your
life 100 we love stay at home moms my
mom was a stay-at-home mom it's such a
gift
um but and you know like yeah that
that's probably in my future sooner than
later and I'm good maybe taking a job
for a year or two and if I have you know
if we get pregnant and we have babies
then I'm gonna be home and you won't
have a need for a master's I wouldn't
get a master's as a safety net for
something in the future that is not
happening now uh if that makes sense
so but but if you but again Jesse on the
other end of the coin if you really do I
mean some people this is not me but some
people love education John John's a lot
he's like this and he's like I just love
learning and school and you know higher
ed and all of that and that's something
that is just that you just really enjoy
and it's a value to you and a passion
for you and it's free and you want to
take the time and go and get that for
yourself and that feels like a big
accomplishment for you uh then I would
say go for it but at that point it
really is a it's a it's a values
question on what on what you want Josie
you know for for your future yeah and
I'm I'm thinking of two sides of this as
well I'm thinking of if you know after a
certain period of time you're going to
want to go back into the workforce there
could be some Merit to having this
because I'm thinking once you have kids
you don't have the same amount of time
sometimes you don't have the same amount
of capacity however there's the other
side of me that's thinking sometimes
after you've had kids you want to do
just something for yourself yeah and you
want and it's kind of like cool having
that waiting for you like okay like I'm
gonna pour into myself I'm gonna go and
I'm wondering will this opportunity to
get the Masters for free will it still
be there on Down the Line
I'm not sure right because I I
um you know I don't have an offer
waiting but it's just almost everyone
that does this program at my college
it's it's paid for they always have
scholarships for
um they only accept three people every
year for this um
opportunity so I I haven't even applied
but I it's there's not many people in my
major at this college and okay I think
I'd have a chance but maybe maybe that
is something I could do down the line
you you're giving me lots of things to
think about well research it I think
right at this point I think you still
have a lot of research to do to to
really be able to funnel out your
options and see where each one leads you
know finding out definitely finding out
how much of a pay raise you would get
find out you know how likely it is that
you actually get this free opportunity
find out how long it would be available
after you've gotten your you know your
initial degree your grad degree how long
you know if it's still going to be there
and you know that'll kind of lead you on
down the line as long as you're not
going into debt over this I feel like
you've got lots of options yeah and I
think as safety net too just is that you
can still go into the classroom without
this like if it was the only thing
blocking you from doing from you know
being able to be in the classroom and
teach I would probably push for you to
get it just just so that you have the
ability to do that job but if you can do
that job still for two years and it's
something that you've gotten your degree
in and that you love and a master degree
is not stopping you from that Apartments
I just go on in the classroom and do
some and work for a few years and then
again when you guys want to start a
family since you know that's going to be
your passion do that and then by the
time like Jade is saying if you ever did
want to go back and get your Masters
honestly Josie from the way you I'm
gonna just predict I could be totally
wrong but for the way you're talking and
how um mature you guys are and probably
hard working you'll probably just cash
flow it even if the opportunity wasn't
there yes in in eight seven eight nine
ten eleven years that's true down the
line too so I would be up to probably
just go in and just start teaching uh
for a few years until you guys start a
family would probably be my but again
that's just me Josie if John Delaney
would probably have a different answer
if he was sitting here too because
there's not a right or wrong there's not
a right or wrong uh when it comes
especially to the to the financial part
of it it's just really a what you want
to do and what do you think Josie what
are you leaning towards
oh man so many things to think about and
such great advice I I think maybe I am
leaning towards just going into the
workforce because it's it I think I I
was worried that this is the only time
I'd have this opportunity right you're
saying that that's not the case and and
you know my life doesn't end once I
leave college right yes that's right
that's an opportunity very cool well
thank you so much for the call that was
a good one it's great Josie thanks for
calling that's a great question very
cool yet again I I just love the calls
Rachel when people call in and they're
not backed into a corner yes they've got
options and I love that you know both of
them they've got this opportunity to get
their masters for free which is amazing
because I'm not going into debt for that
one that's amazing very very cool well
folks that does it for this hour of the
show be sure to join us next time and I
want you to remember this when it comes
to changing your life and your money you
can tell me that you can't do it but
don't tell me that you won't do it hey
what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am your
host today Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality and I'm joined by fellow
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz and today
we're taking calls about your life your
money give us a call the number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and with that let's go straight to
the phone lines We've Got Sabrina from
Huntington West Virginia what's going on
Sabrina
hello hi
um I just had a question mine is about
career changes I'm currently a teacher
I've been teaching for about 11 years in
the public school system and
um and looking to possibly change
careers based on low wages they've like
honestly we just got a raise and then
they raise their insurance enough to get
rid of our raise the first race that
we've had since like 1980. shoot
um so I'm looking
to see like that's going to really take
a hit to our budget even without you
know so I just didn't know like if it's
at 40 years old is it a good idea to
change careers completely
um
I I basically did that if that makes you
feel any better I did I'm not 40 yet but
I'm 39 and I switched careers I just was
like we're doing something different now
so can it be done yes
um
is it easy no
um and do you sometimes question
yourself yes but I think for you it
starts with figuring out what else that
you would want to do
right and figuring out what else you're
good at and you have an idea of what
that might be
um I
I'm definitely a service
oriented person I'm serving kids and
families mostly I've looked at a couple
of Physicians uh locally that are not
really in that field well it's through
like the VA Medical Center
um that I would qualify for but they're
serving a you know a veterans
um but it's more clerical work so um I
mean it's something definitely I could
change
um
if I could get one of those positions uh
that would be something I could I could
see myself doing but how much of a pay
raise would it be Sabrina
um almost that will almost double yeah
interesting what does it take to be
qualified for that
um I mean a lot of them I qualify for
just by having a I have my Master's
Degree that some of them are just
looking for somebody with a bachelor's
degree
um and not really any experience so when
I started looking at income and I like
teachers have never been in it for the
income you hear that cliche in it for
the outcome not the income but
my my budget and my family you know it's
like I can't keep doing the same thing
sure does it require remove
no no and some of them are actually
fully remote so I would be at home
um oh wow so that would even be
different as well
um my my youngest is starting a private
school in the fall and
um
being able like not having to worry
about getting him to school and things
like that would I would be able to do
that easier I think as well
um with a different position sure I do
enjoy teaching and I enjoy the school
I've been at the same school for 11
years so you know it's hardly those kids
but in the same the same attitude it's
like it's so much harder harder and
harder to teach yes um totally
physically mentally yeah yeah and what's
so you know yeah on that side of the
coin I'm like you know my kids are in
school my daughter's in the second grade
and every teacher she's had in a public
you know we're in public school here
outside of Nashville and they're just
incredible like the teachers are just
they're such a gift
um the service they do their hearts for
these kids and all of it so I hear that
in you Sabrina on that end so like I
want to applaud that and hold teachers
with such esteem because they play such
a crucial role
um but then also in the same breath too
as I'm talking to you Sabrina as a whole
person not just the teacher but as a mom
and a wife and you know all these other
roles that who you are and what you guys
need financially to support the kind of
life that that you want and that
um you know even your son starting a
private school like all those things
come into play of hey here are our
expenses and here's just the math here
is the reality of what we're at and
sometimes you have to make those hard
decisions and it's not saying that
um you know that it's it's right or
wrong to leave for the money but I think
there's a point that's like I have to
support my family I had a friend he was
a teacher and they had four kids and it
was to the point that he was like I
can't and she was a stay-at-home mom and
she was like I just we can't live on
this and so that's that's the sad
reality and so I think that's probably
kind of where you're at is you're
holding both of those and both can be
true Sabrina both can be true that you
loved what you did but that same service
oriented heart that you have in the
classroom can be put in other positions
uh in in the marketplace in other ways
that's right that you can still have
that same outcome for you because that
isn't who you are obviously you've done
this you know teaching job for 11 years
so to keep that as part of you I think
will be really important for the health
of
um the the outcome and the joy that you
have in your next job is to kind of keep
that same Spirit about you I agree and
the other thing about this Sabrina is
teaching's not going anywhere so if you
transitioned that's a great point and
you transition to this clerical work at
the VA or whatever that looks like and
you just became empty inside and you're
like I hate this I've got to go back to
it would still be there waiting or maybe
you decided hey I'm gonna do this job
um for the next decade while my kids are
this age and while things are very
expensive and then after this I'm going
to go back to teaching like you've got a
lot of options to sort through but other
than that it's like what's stopping you
from starting to apply for some of these
jobs yeah yeah that's true the only
other thing is a little
I had a I do have my masters and that's
where I do have student loan debt from
that and so it's like I'm ashamed that
oh I'm Gonna Leave This position after
I've
um oh oh on this degree still no that's
a lie no don't do that I'll say majority
of people don't use their degree
surprise so you're not going to be the
first I left my degree yeah I feel this
Sabrina I'm with you I'm like look
pivoting at almost 40 it's not easy but
you can definitely do it especially and
I feel you on the I but I got my degree
in this and I spent all this money I
when you said that I felt that deep in
my core
um so I understand that but I think you
can do this how much student loan debt
do you have by the way uh 50 000 50k is
that the only debt you guys have uh we
have a little bit of Consumer Debt
besides that um we're we're working
we're in babysit too we've actually been
able to pay off two credit cards and a
loan since January oh great job all
right we'll be debt free except the
student loans and we don't have a
mortgage either but we should be debt
free by January oh way to go if we keep
on what we're doing yeah that was
another thing is like you know we're
using all this money right now to make
sure we're
um we're paying everything off so yeah
that's great yeah and if you ever do
step out and take a higher paying job
Serena just the lifestyle will creep is
real so make sure you are disciplined
with that double this time that is true
however if they're debt free in January
and they've got all that income back
freedom I wonder how she would feel
about teaching after that point because
now there's more money available that's
a great Point too cool that's a great
call Sabrina think that through too I
just threw another little curve there at
you but this is you know this is it you
can pivot you can change you can have an
act two whatever that means for you
you're capable of more than what you
ever imagined this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey you're listening to the Ramsay show
thanks for listening to us guys uh if
you want to talk on the line with us and
have me or Rachel or both of us talk to
you about your situation you can do that
give us a call the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we'll try to be nice you know for
the most part I think that we uh you
know we are nice I feel like we tame
each other down a little bit let's work
right you know tough love kind love
um and with that I am told that there's
something that we all need to see and
I'm trying to remember James if I've
seen this video or not or is this just
going to be a clean reaction Rachel sent
this to me so I don't know if you've
seen or not but Rachel's seen it yeah I
saw this a few weeks ago I think it was
just funny I think it's like this
comedian talking about uh mortgage rates
and mortgages so here here check it out
all right let's see it
I've been paying my mortgage but
according to this I haven't even made a
dent my original loan was 240 000 I've
been paying my mortgage for six months
and I still owe 239 000 you see why that
would piss me off so I bought a 300 000
home but in 30 this is gonna cost like
1.8 million dollars is this escrow's
fault I don't know what that is still so
I just kind of blame it on that that's
fine if you want to blame it escrow you
can okay I hate that guy they say the
rate is fixed do they call it that
because it feels like I'm being neutered
oh gosh
I know people were sending me that I was
like that's funny because it is funny
it's just how it feels when you're
paying interest and you're just like oh
my gosh yeah and I mean I'll be honest
until you buy a house I think there's so
many unknown fees and things that you
don't know about until it gets there and
then you're like oh I gotta pay this too
yeah it's all wrapped in there together
and yeah it's yep it can be a lot I
remember what's the fee oh gosh off the
top of my head I'm not even remembering
what when when you're gonna buy the
house and it's like you're making good
on not your down payment but like that
little piece it starts with an E gosh I
can't remember what's called it's like
yeah do you know what I'm talking about
yes it's a lot of money though and you
have to like it's like customary to put
this money there I don't remember what
it's called no not escrow
Sam is trying to tell me in the I can't
remember what it's called but there's so
much money that you have to pay it's
like all right there's the down payment
and then there's this money and that
money and and there's this and this and
this and this and this and this and then
you get the statement earnest money
thank you earnest money y'all I'm out
here sounding like I don't know a thing
but I'm telling you it's earnest money
and it's sometimes it's like 10 20 000.
yes it's cash money that's the hard
thing about about real estate again as
we were talking about home ownership is
is the American dream it's the thing
everyone wants and it's a and it's a
great part of your financial picture but
yeah man it it can be such a downer when
you're not financially ready and that's
why we always say it's these surprises
that come up yes within the mortgage
process and everything associated with
it but also just home ownership in
general when when something breaks yeah
and you're the one that has to pay for
it needs to put your money there versus
doing you know you got it saved it for
something else so you just feel the
pinch and the pain when it comes to
homeownership even though it's great
um but when broke people buy a house we
always have to say make some broker
Brokers because it it adds on the stress
it does not give you the peace and the
blessing that you think so being in a
position for home ownership when you
don't have debt you have money in the
bank saved for a rainy day you just have
yourself in a good position and a good
down payments you know that all of those
things that formula just sets you up for
this to be a blessing not a curse not to
mention the move the move itself is
offensive yes just the move and you know
I was talking to Sam and I were talking
about this um because all the stuff
that's circulating about
um the new format structure for the
llpas and all that stuff that's been in
the news from the Biden Administration
you know it's I I think that I feel like
people are really
um High Strung right now and I'm not
saying there's not cause you know
interest rates are higher these new fees
are popping out but there's something to
be said I think a lot of folks have
forgotten especially home first time
home buyers like real estate is a ladder
you know yes you sometimes you come in
and you start on that Bottom Rung and I
I really do feel Rachel that because of
HGTV and social media and all these
things I feel like a lot of times
first-time homebuyers feel like this
pressure like I can't come in at less
than half a million and I'm like you
might need to yes you might start out
with a condo like there's you might have
to start at the bottom and work your way
further up that ladder build up some
Equity then sell and then take that and
roll it over into the next house you
know and that's kind of how Sam and I
started our first house you know
we rented and then we saved for a long
time and then we had a our first house
and then we rolled that into a little
bit of a nicer house and that's kind of
how it works and I just think that it's
worth taking the time to do it and do it
right so that yeah those things that
you're talking about the fees and the
moving and all of that that you can do
it and it's something that's enjoyable
and it's a blessing and it's not a
burden that's right that's right yeah
and the expectation
of owning a home and when to own a home
and the type of home just making sure
that it's not all out of whack because
again I think the the normalcy bar of
what life says yeah is unrealistic right
I mean people graduate from college like
I should or get you know your first year
married it's like I should own a home I
should own a home and it's like but if
you don't if you're not in the financial
position then no and the type of home to
your point that you may own as you know
just starting out your starter home
that's why they call it a starter home
uh it's gonna look different yeah it's
not gonna be your appearance yes we
think that we're automatically going to
have our parents house and our parents
cars and our parents salary and it's
like no bro it took them a long time to
build that up that's right and it's okay
for that so just a little two cents
there on that whole situation but yeah I
digress let's take a call let's talk to
Danielle she's in Canton Ohio what's
going on Danielle
hi guys
Hi how are you
um good how are you doing good how can
we help
um yeah so
um I'm kind of in a predicament right
now I'm very high anxiety right now okay
um
my uh our house is up for sale right now
we just built it
um in 2018 and we love our home it's
beautiful it screams like modern
Farmhouse like we have about 23 Acres we
love our house
um we put it up for sale and we just got
a cash offer for 480 000
um and now we're having like cold feet
so my son is going to start Junior High
this year
um the new school year and he's into
wrestling like we're really really into
wrestling we take into wrestling clubs
we um he does like private lessons he
goes to the gym okay
um keep going so we have time to answer
you okay so living here is just costing
us too much to have him wrestle
but so if we say we gotta really like
cut back the wrestling he can't pursue
it we're thinking about moving to a
different School District so he's close
to his gym his Club it's a more intense
wrestling program at this school but you
know we're looking at other houses on
the market like we can't afford to have
the same thing that we have with the
interest rates that are up the new Biden
thing
um and I'm just starting to have cold
feet like is this stupid are we moving
for a sport like is that financially you
know yeah well I mean it sounds like at
the end of the day if you choose to move
you've got to be able to afford where
you're moving to
if you can't afford it
you know or it may not or you're gonna
have to downgrade is basically what
you're saying Danielle and so yeah we're
gonna have to downgrade so as a family I
think that's here yeah I think as a
family you and your husband he doesn't
need your the fifth grader doesn't need
to be making the decision you and your
husband need to look at your financial
picture together and as a family beyond
the financial picture and say hey what
do we want our life to be structured
some people right on the sports category
they go all in and they're gone every
weekend they're doing travel Sports and
that's what they choose to do other
families say no we're not going to allow
that we're gonna put boundaries they can
do rec league but we're not traveling
every weekend so we're gonna put because
not because of money but just time with
family it's a value right so you guys
don't need to let his wrestling be the
thing that is driving all these
decisions you guys as a family need to
be driving these decisions So Daniel I
would get on the same page with your
husband on how much this wrestling is
going to be a part of your life because
it's there's going to be no there's been
no break pedal when it comes to kids
sports except for the parents society's
not going to break it coaches aren't
going to be your brake pedal it can get
it can go out of control and again it's
not a bad thing but if that's what you
choose to do but you guys need to make a
boundary for your family and say hey
what do we want our life to look like
time wise with this wrestling
and what does this look like financially
for us and are we okay downgrading
because if you say yeah we no boundaries
with the wrestling all in we're going
and we're gonna downgrade the house and
we're gonna do it that's great that's
what you guys are choosing to do but I
don't want you to look up and say wow we
made a financial decision based on a
sixth grade sports that he doesn't even
want to do in two years so again
you just need to create a higher level
boundary conversation Danielle um and I
would recommend you and your husband do
that tonight this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
what's going on guys you're listening to
the Ramsay show I'm your host Jade
warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz give us a
call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five now here's
the thing
there is some very very very weird stuff
going on in the labor market and it is
crushing small business owners they've
had to deal with the great resignation
they've had to deal with quiet quitting
and a lack of skilled workers it has
been absolutely Relentless now to put
this chaos into perspective we've got
political Economist Nicholas eberstadt
who's found that in the recent seven
who's found that in recent years seven
million able-bodied males have left the
workforce and have not come back seven
million am I reading that's crazy hold
on I gotta say that again
seven million able-bodied males have
left the workforce and had it come back
that means that y'all are what are y'all
doing are you at home are you just
chilling are you sitting on there maybe
the wife has gone back to work I don't
know that's interesting I want to know
more about this well here's here's our
chance it sounds insane and it's not
okay this Mass Exodus of workers is
changing what work looks like in America
and I've heard Ken talk about this
um it's it's a lot of folks don't want
to do the type of work that's out there
which is oh interesting yeah yeah yeah
and and so it's a huge contributor to
the labor shortest shortage gosh that we
find ourselves in today we need workers
guys so we're closing out Small Business
Week uh with an event that you cannot
miss because business owners need to
know how to make it to the other side of
this mess so this week on Thursday May
4th Dave Ramsey is going to be teaming
up with Mike Rowe and five best-selling
authors and experts for our America's
labor crisis live stream they'll talk
about the state of work in America today
including the facts behind this labor
crisis and they'll give Business Leaders
real solutions to help them deal with
the hiring challenges that they're
facing so you do not want to miss this
it's a free live stream and if you're
local we still have a few seats that are
left for you to attend this event in our
brand new event center hey that's
amazing so you can register uh by
visiting ramseysolutions.com
labor crisis that's so interesting Jade
and I so wonder I haven't read that yet
and so I'm like I I would be so cute I
would be curious I'd want to I might
listen to the live stream to see it yeah
to see what they talk about because I'm
like you know covet changed a lot it did
it did
um and I think families are changing you
know the new what it looks like for the
you know the
you know from the 1950s picture of you
know the wife staying home and you know
the man goes off to work you know even
the family Dynamics in America are
changing it's true and dual incomes is
still a huge thing so I'm like I wonder
if is it the type of work is it the
family Dynamic the way that's changing
in America is it that yeah there's that
people think that they're above certain
jobs so they won't go and do certain
jobs because of that is it you know I'm
like well I I would be so curious what
where that stat you know it also makes
you wonder with covid too I think there
could be a lot of like I remember
talking briefly to Dave about this you
know covid told a lot of people that
they weren't essential and that they
didn't matter yeah and you know maybe
you were in a job for however many years
and then they told you laid off and yeah
they told you you don't matter anymore
yeah that's not true right you know that
can that can mess with your psyche right
right great deal yeah oh that's so
interesting isn't that interesting
fascinating that'll be a great live
stream you are needed and I like micro
he the dirty job
he's he's so great and so I bet there's
a level of that of you know certain
parts of the workforce the labor force
that maybe are you know more physically
yes strained versus like a typical just
office job right like how that's even
shifting but there's so much dignity in
those jobs we need people to do and
that's what I'm wondering and what's
what's interesting too and I'd be one of
my kid says I have so many thoughts
where you know even trade school is
starting to grow even more massive and
and I think that people are waking up to
the idea that like gosh a college degree
is it is there really an Roi yeah and
spending all this money for a degree for
college when I could go and be a plumber
and and own my own business and make
great money doing that you know what I
mean so the trades I feel like are kind
of having a comeback that's true from
things I've read too so I'm curious how
that plays into there's there's a lot
I'm thinking of the other side of it
what I guess now you got me because I'm
like we're not in the event we're just
we're just speculating here of all the
reasons people might be leaving the
workforce my other thought is during
covid people could work from home yeah
and then they got used to working from
home and then it's like hey come back
and it's like wait I don't want to come
back oh yeah no I was able to make the
same money from home what are you gonna
give me and if those offices aren't like
we're not raising your pay we're not
doing this it's like well I say
something else yes oh man you know what
I'm gonna go to this I'm gonna go live
in person I'm not gonna do the live
stream
let's take a call let's go to Ryan or
Brian I'm sorry in Minneapolis mini
Annapolis mini I can't say it
Minneapolis Minnesota
thanks for taking my call absolutely how
can we help
no problem um so a little bit of pretext
we're feeling stuck me and my wife
um we're currently on baby step two
I'm a full-time IP guy she is a
part-time CNA or you know one step below
an RN in the nursing scale flip that in
terms of schooling she's a full-time
student on halftime and we're just
seeing like every time we we get to a
point where we can pay a debt off
instead of being able to roll that money
in the snowball we have to put it
towards something else all of our bills
are constantly shifting and we're just
feeling like we're kind of stuck in this
puddle of never being able to get out of
baby step two
hmm so you're both still in school
whether full-time or part-time are you
cash flowing that school
no uh I am not able to she is she's
going to community college but my my
four year that I'm working on my
bachelor's uh I'm not able to afford a
bankroll
okay so we're in baby step two can you
go through kind of list out your debts
let's go through the whole picture let's
go through debts and incomes and see
what's going on
sure so prior to meeting me uh she
bought a 20 000 brand new off a lot to
you
um we have paid for that mistake every
day since we got together but we are
down to 2K left on that okay I have
about 7 000 left in credit cards she's
got about two
um all said and done we're sitting at
about 56 Grand worth of of debt between
student loans uh her car loan couple
credit cards
and uh so two hospital bills so 56 000
all rolled into one
yeah this is even when you finish your
school
so that that's pending any other uh
money I have to put on student loans at
this point
okay so there'll be more student loans
when you're done
correct okay and the reason that so the
time frame versus uh bankrolling this is
if you could talk about and everybody
everybody else on Ramsey network is the
fact that the degree I'm going for puts
me in a position for federal law
enforcement and unfortunately there's a
time frame on that if I if I hit a
certain age I no longer qualify so that
that's the sake of the time crop
okay
um and how much is and you don't know
what that's what the total amount is
going to be yet or do you know
at this point I would wager about 25 000
more okay and how much you guys make
um average income per month is about 3
600.
3600 a month
correct okay and that's not including
any side Hustle the side hustle even is
kind of all over the place right now I'm
doing instacart so I'm trying to make a
little bit more money that way but it's
uh it varies so much based on
availability of orders and all that
other stuff sure how much a month
roughly would you say you make doing
that
can you speak directly into your phone
we're having a hard time hearing you
Brian sure instead of three dollars a
month there yeah
I I didn't hear you again one more time
three three hundred dollars a month 300
a month okay
well yeah I mean you guys you're I mean
you're taking home about 40 a a year
with 56 000 in debt so yeah you probably
are feeling it
um and feeling stuck and so something
something does have to shift
um and I don't know if that's her
pausing her school Brian and going to
work full time uh I don't know if that's
you saying hey I know there's a time
crunch here but for I'm gonna pause for
12 months and come back to the school
and go work somewhere full time to get
this debt under control because I mean
yeah yeah I mean you guys have I mean
more depth than you're making a year and
I know that's not going to be forever
because you're going to be out but
you're going to also be having another
25 000 in debt so yeah you're not going
to make much progress with the current
Formula you're you're living on so
something's got to change and I don't
know again if that's her pausing school
and going in full time but you probably
won't make much progress unless you get
your incomes up that's that's the key
there's a major sacrifice that's going
to have to take place you're going to
have to get your income up my guess is
your your expenses are already down so
here comes the sacrifice it's time to
make a cut this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey Show hey
thanks for hanging out with us I'm your
host Jade warshaw joined by my other
host right next to me Rachel Cruz and um
man we're having a good time we have
enjoyed your calls if you want to call
and talk to us we'll talk about whatever
is on your mind uh just as long as it
has a little something something to do
with money it could be careers it could
be relationships whatever that is give
us a call the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five we'll
talk about your grocery budget whatever
you want to talk about we're here for
that and um before I go much further
thank you James Sometimes James talks in
my ear he said don't forget the
scripture and I won't I would never
forget the Lord James scripture and
quote of the day he says fear not for I
am with you be not dismayed for I am
your God I will strengthen you I will
help you I will uphold you with my
righteous right hand Isaiah 41 10. love
that uh and then we've got this one from
Joanna Gaines I love Joanna Gaines she
says don't quit don't give up the reward
is just around the corner and in times
of Doubt or times of Joy listen for that
still Small Voice know that God has been
there from the beginning and he will be
there till the end so good a Joanna
gainesco well done guys that was good I
felt like that was just for us that was
perfect love her love her well let's see
what Corrin is talking about she's in
Kansas City Missouri what's going on
Corinne hey thank you so much for taking
my call you're welcome thanks for
calling in
um so my son and I were in a small car
accident a few weeks ago and we are both
receiving a small settlement check and I
was curious if it made sense to invest
my son's check and if so what are my
options
um to invest it to where he could not
only use it for college but um trade
school or if you wanted to start his own
business but basically just not
pigeonhole him into college if that
makes sense yeah I'm so sorry is
everyone okay
yeah we're good okay gosh and how much
is this settlement gonna be
uh one thousand dollars a thousand
dollars okay are you both receiving
money or just your son
oh we both are okay and as yours a
thousand dollars as well
yes okay so two thousand and how old is
he
he is nine months old oh man I'm so glad
you guys are okay I know that's scary
my goodness
um
I mean honestly
I mean it's a thousand dollars
so I would for him I mean even just open
up just a high yield savings account and
you could just do something just to have
the cash on hands because I just think
for him
going
you I mean you could go down the road of
like doing an upma which is a universal
transfer miners act which causes you to
put a mutual fund or a type of
investment in his name and you could go
through all of that if you wanted for a
thousand dollars I don't know if that'd
be worth it I almost would lean towards
just putting it in a high yield savings
account for him and it's not and you're
doing it not really as like a
quote-unquote investment but it's just
having that cash available to him
because as he gets older
and I think about it 16 for a car heck
yeah um yeah if he wants to use this
money later I mean you know it it it
could make money in the market if you
wanted to open up a mutual fund
something I mean that's that's a lot to
do but you could uh but you also could
just have that cash available for him
something that you could get to easily
and even I mean correct I mean I would
even be okay that it's like yeah if um I
don't know what would come up for him
younger than 16 I mean a car is the
biggest purchase I can think of but if
there's something else that happens that
you're like oh yeah we could use that
money uh for him in this way uh it's
just available to you more
um would you invent would you go through
opening uh I might I here's where here's
where my brains are tracking I'm
thinking two things I'm thinking if
she's thinking about college but we're
not quite to like the 529 or you know if
she wanted and she's maybe you're I
don't know what baby step you're on
let's say you're on baby step four and
you're already in the habit of investing
or you kind of have a thought for that
you might throw it in a brokerage or you
might throw it somewhere where it's like
growing a little bit more than a high
yield part of me likes an investment
because then
you can't just pull it out if you hit on
hard times or like something pulls up
but then because ideally my thought is
like I I don't know that there's a wrong
answer here I don't know that there is
yeah because are you familiar with our
baby steps Karen
I am yeah so what baby stuff are you on
we are on two
um just in a holding pattern uh we only
have student loans left and right now
they would be theoretically forgiven and
so um if they are cool and if not then
at that point that decisions made uh we
have the ability to go ahead and pay
them off oh and that's right
and when you're saying those they're
going to be forgiven is that through the
Biden Administration everything that's
been going on in the news
or the Public Service
of the Biden Administration comes out
they're not paying those but then when
we'll pay them at that time yes okay I
would go and pay it if I were you it's
probably not going to happen I mean I I
wouldn't wait on them to become debt
free so if you have the money I would go
ahead and do that and then for your son
yeah I think you're right uh Jade as you
were talking I mean yeah it may be worth
looking into opening up yeah a brokerage
account or even a Vanguard or doing
something that you can just put some
money in yeah and let it grow and let it
grow some
um with everything being up and down I
just don't want you to I want you to run
the math out on it because I think
sometimes we talk about compound
interest that is very real yes but it's
also like it's not going to be a million
dollars like I think sometimes we can
inflate that idea so run some numbers
and just like yeah for 12 you know yeah
over the course of 18 years what is this
going to be at 18 and that can be a
really nice yeah gift to give him
um so yeah I'm changing my answer
I'm thinking that or even if she just
wanted to go ahead and just throw it
into a 529 maybe she's not there on the
baby steps yet to continue to contribute
to it yeah well she said she didn't want
to she didn't want to do education oh
that's right you did say that I'm sorry
so I wonder yeah if it's a brokerage
type account or
a Vanguard kind of thing and index funds
or just something that's like really
simple yep that you
um that you're not looking at this as
his retirement or something that's like
you know if we're talking in those
discussions if it was in that language
or that circumstance it would be
something a lot more formal yeah
um but yeah I would like I would like in
something like that but it's a great
question and yeah I'm so thankful y'all
are okay yes me too thank you for the
call that was a good one uh I think
we've got time let's take another one
we've got kalistis in Dallas Texas I
love that name what's going on callistus
hey how's it going how's it going doing
good how are you
doing good doing good kind of a in a bit
of a pickle right now uh we we bought a
house
um about
six months ago um and now we're kind of
left in a hole so we're not sure you
know we should stay or if we should move
and you know rent an apartment for some
time before we're able to you know pay
off some debt I'll pay some cars off so
that way we're in a better position so
what caused you to be in a pickle is it
that it's just too much for your monthly
budget or
yeah so um long story short when we we
bought the house back in November
um and you know my wife got a real good
job so we were both making real good
money
um so we decided you know what we have
about nine thousand dollars worth of
credit card debt left over so let's
let's just buy the house now because of
how the market is never know how the
rates can be and you know with people
buying up all these homes in Dallas
there may not be any more left over in a
couple years that's not true
yeah yeah oh yeah we know that now but
we we decided to to buy the house
um and then after we moved a lot of
things took place I tore my kiwis my
wife lost her job and now where we had
all the income to be able to afford the
house
um
yeah so what are you paying very much
what are you paying a month um in
mortgage
um which HOA is 37.50 and what's your
current take-home pay that you're taking
in between your wife and you combined
uh combined right now
um it's it's 94 but we do take out our
ties as well so it's 83 000 a year I
mean a month can you break that down for
me monthly real quick
yes sure
I just want to see what percentage
you're at with this mortgage payment
because we would say we don't want it to
be more than 25 my guess is yours
probably is and that's why you're
feeling such a pinch and if that's the
case then we're going to have to find a
way to either get your income up lower
your expenses only you know is there a
place in your budget that you can start
cutting some expenses to get some
breathing room until you guys can get
your because your wife is your wife back
in the work is she looking for another
job will she have
yeah she's she's looking for one right
now and I did calculate it right now at
um a month with 69 16 a month okay
usually we have left over yeah you're
feeling that much
so we've got to get that income up
that's your that you know we've got to
get your wife working again if she's out
of the workforce for too long you might
have to consider getting out of this but
in the meantime you've got to find a way
to get that income up because you got to
make these payments yeah it'll have to
be a a quick turn for her to to get
something
um to make some money yeah and if this
is something that's gonna shift if it's
gonna take a year I would say sell it
and get out because it won't be worth it
but if you think she can replace it in
the next 30 60 days if she has some
leads happening then you guys might be
okay and there will be more houses on
the market when you need them don't let
that fear stop you from doing uh what
you ultimately need to do and what you
ultimately know is right to do for you
and your family this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]